hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i
am a property investor and in this video
i wanted to for the first time ever
reveal
how i intend to become a billionaire
now when i was a kid i always had an
entrepreneurial hunger
i wanted to win i wanted to win big and
i started in business
and i became successful in business
however
i realized that to become a billionaire
is not something that happens by
accident and i spent a long time
strategizing speaking to mentors
ridiculously successful people i've been
coached by billionaires
and i'm not a billionaire yet but in
this video for the first time ever i'm
going to talk about how i intend to do
what my business plan looks like
so if you appreciate me putting this out
then do me a massive favor and smash the
like button also if you want to join me
in the
uh becoming a billionaire challenge then
i'm gonna i'm at the end of the video
i'm gonna
give a special invitation to you which
is a free on the house invitation
so stay watching until the very end of
the video so a little bit back story
about my me and business is when i was a
kid i used to do paper rounds
now when i used to do paper rounds that
used to make me money that was what i
did to make money
when i left school i realized that paper
rounds
wasn't going to get me rich so i thought
well what's going to get me rich
property investment real estate so i got
into real estate and i use strategies as
you'll probably know
like deal sourcing lease option
agreements joint venture agreements
rent to rents to get into property to
get my foot in the door
and to stop building a portfolio i
thought this is gonna make me rich
this is it now listen it succeeded
i did become successful in property and
my goal
was to own a thousand houses it was
actually only in 2017
when i met lord alan sugar that he told
me that my business plan
sucked i'm like what do you mean my
business plan
sucks i've got you know dozens and
dozens of houses
and i want to get to a thousand houses
surely that's a good plan real estate
property is a really good investment i
know lord sugar himself
is a massive real estate investor but
here's what he told me
he told me that my plan of continuing
doing what i was doing which was buying
just buy to let's buying properties
turning them into hmos renting them out
he told me that that would never make me
massive money i'm like what now listen
he's a billionaire okay what i realized
was my
plan of buying houses and renting them
out
although it was a good plan and you
could become you know a millionaire
doing that
i was already a millionaire when i met
lord sugar now i'm a multi-millionaire
but let me tell you something
a billionaire a billion is
a million a million a million a million
a million a million a million a million
a million a million a minute a thousand
times
what i realized was that in the same way
as doing paper rounds wasn't going to
make me a millionaire
i realized that buying houses and
renting them
out wasn't going to make me a
billionaire
maybe it could make me a millionaire not
a billionaire i realized that even
the deals i was doing at the time that i
considered really profitable deals
like if i you know bought a property
pushed the value up
refinanced it rented it out i realized
that it wasn't
i'd have to do that so many times
and realistically just wasn't a feasible
plan so
from that meeting i ended up getting
grant cardone as a business mentor as
well so i spent a lot of time
with grant cardone still still still
speak to brandt today
and my plans changed and in this video
i'm going to talk about what the plan is
if you're enjoying this so far
hit the like button so a few years ago
i secured a piece of land and i secured
this piece of land in buckinghamshire
on a lease option agreement now i've
been
i've been doing these option agreements
for years on residential houses
after securing this piece of land on a
lease option agreement
i then got planning permission to build
on the land
and when i got planning permission it
pushed the value of the land up
by over a hundred thousand pounds
i'm like wow i then reassigned the
option
sold it onto a self-built developer and
profited clean profit in my bank
of about and two thousand pounds clean
profit
the whole thing took me nine months i'm
thinking
if i buy a house and rent it out and it
gives me a thousand pounds of profit a
month
i get to wait a hundred months a hundred
months to achieve what i just achieved
in nine months on this one deal
not only that but this land deal that i
just did i could do that on a massively
bigger scale
i could secure a piece of land instead
of getting planning permission to build
two houses on it like i did
i could get plenty of people to build 50
houses on it
and and as i was doing this more and
more and i was finding pieces of land
and getting planning permission on it
with an optional agreement and then
passing the land on
i then realized hang on a minute i could
not only could i get
a piece of land and get an option on it
and get planning permission to build on
it
and push the value up because profits in
the planning but i could also
could then get a development finance
loan or bring in joint ventures
and i could actually build myself so i
then started
building houses now to this at this
present time i've got a hundred
million pounds worth of deals in the
pipeline i've got multiple deals going
on i've secured four
sites in buckinghamshire over the last
three months
so my plan to become a billionaire is
not property investment
it's property development
that's what i am focusing on at the
moment now is property investment good
yes is it the quickest way to become
financially free
yes it's fantastic i wouldn't change
anything that i've done
but right now i'm just speaking it out
by the way and telling
you as a subscriber what i'm doing i'm
focusing more on
property development that is buying
pieces of land
building houses securing them on option
agreements
buying large properties and splitting
them up title splitting commercial to
residential this
is property development now that's what
i'm doing it's all new for me i'm
learning because i've been in pro
i've been a property investor for 10
years before
really hardcore getting into property
development i've now been in property in
total for just over 12 years
if you want to join me on this
journey of property development i have
put on a
one day training program called the
secrets of property development
intensive
i'd like to invite you to come and join
me at the property development
secrets live training program this is a
one day course it is free to attend and
you can get the details on
property www.propertyhigh investors dot
code uk forward slash
development i'm going to be revealing
the secrets
to how i transitioned from a property
investor
to a property developer making six
figure
profits on every property deal that i do
we're going to be talking about tax
about land about building houses from
scratch
if i was to make 250 000 pound profit
per property deal
i'd need to do fewer deals but ones
which made a lot more money
often it only takes a billionaire a few
minutes to change the course of another
person's life
when you speak things out you speak them
into
existence so get down to the property
development secret live course i cannot
wait to meet you in person
i'm going to be sharing exactly
what deals i am working on at the moment
i'm going to share the deals that i have
successfully done the ones i've got in
the pipeline but more importantly
how you can get into property
development too
whether you are already a property
investor whether you're already a
property developer or whether you're
just starting out brand new
i would like to invite you to join me at
the property development secrets
intensive and let me tell you something
i'm putting this training program on and
i'm putting it on
for free to my youtube subscribers so if
you are subscribed to my channel if
you're not hit subscribe
there's a link in the description it's
completely free
there is a one pound booking fee that's
just to check you're a real person
but the event itself the program is free
it's coming up soon
i'd love to see you there get registered
and let me show you
the secret to property development
thanks for watching
click the link below i'll see you there